[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et l'heure d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
bienvenue dans cette édition tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 30 avril
demain c'est le 1er mai jour de la fête
du travail vous n'échapperez pas comme
chaque année à la tradition du muguet le
rendez vous se prépare chez les
fleuristes là mais aussi dans les
sections locales du parti communiste des
yvelines une vente non négligeable pour
la santé financière de la fédération le
10 mai c'est la journée nationale des
mémoires de la traite de l'esclavagé et
de leurs abolitions à cette occasion une
semaine spéciale sur la thématique est
organisée à saint quentin en yvelines la
10e édition débute vendredi à nous en
parlons avec marilyn les yeux secrétaire
du collectif qui organise cet événement
et puis la 15e prairial se déroulait ce
week end à montigny le bretonneux près
de 15000 visiteurs se sont rendus à la
ferme du manet des fonds ont été
récoltés pour financer un chien guide
d'aveuglé reportage autres invités de ce
journal gym ou type au diacre de la
paroisse orthodoxe saint jean à kassian
et sainte geneviève
elle est installée à trappes depuis 2012
c'est à suivre dans ce journal avant de
développer ces titres il se retire
temporairement pour raisons de santé le
maire sans étiquette de coignières
jean-pierre sevestre a vu son état
s'aggraver soudainement ce week end
il ne sera donc pas en mesure d'assurer
ses fonctions dédiées les deux vice
présidentes saint quentin en yvelines
dans les prochaines semaines à
conséquence le conseil municipal de ce
mercredi qui devait et lancer le
processus de rapprochement entre
coignard et maurepas est annulé et d'ab
inbev david pelletier élus aux finances
assurera les délégations de jean-pierre
sevestre jusqu'à à la fin du mois de mai
au moins et des bureaux ministériels
attrape marlène schiappa va délocaliser
à l'activité de son cabinet pendant
trois jours dans la ville yvelinoise à
la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
sera sur place mercredi jeudi et
vendredi prochains au programme visites
de terrain rencontre avec les acteurs
locaux élus associations et entreprises
et nous reviendrons largement sur la
présence de marlène schiappa à trappes
dans nos éditions de la semaine
je vous en parlais dans les titres en
cette veille de 1er mai les vendeurs de
muguet se prépare à un moment
portons pour les fleuristes et mais
aussi pour le parti communiste des
yvelines qui organise sa vente
traditionnels reportage de marie lehn
iapichino marion ptac et nicolas
nombreux les cheminots de versailles
c'est la base actuelle le parti
communiste prépare comme chaque année sa
vente traditionnels de brins de muguet
dans les yvelines les adhérents jouent
les apprentis fleuristes et prépare les
commandes de chaque section
ça permet tous les ans de rencontrer des
gens on voit pas spécialement dans nos
locaux mais qui viennent à notre
rencontre
ils nous connaissent 18 sections des
yvelines vendront leurs clochettes de
man la fédération a commandé entre sept
et dix palettes car cette vente
représente une source de revenus non
négligeable pour le parti le parti
communiste n'a pas les mêmes moyens que
les gros partis politiques qui eux
engrangé énormément d'argent via les
fonds publics
des brins politique qui pourront être
accompagnées de roses rouges
alors pour se différencier des ventes
sauvages tolérer le 1er mai les
fleuristes joue la carte de la qualité
donc nous en tant que fleurissent pas
notre rôle c'est de rester sur une
qualité exemplaire donc pour ça et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et il faut faire
très très attention lors de nos achats
la météo humide et fraîche puis très
chaude à abîmer les brins de muguet
coupée sur les halles de rungis où se
fournissent les professionnels ont
dénombré huit cent mille points de moins
que l'année précédente
cette année le muguet se vendra donc
avec racines pour qu'il soit bon au
niveau des clochettes vous voyez sont
bien blanche
il ya encore du bouton et puis sont pas
transparents détour donc ceci voilà ça
c'est à nous avons muguet ça qu'elle est
un brin communiste ou des racines pour
une qualité et les pros châble les
clochettes du muguet sonneront la fête
du travail et le retour du printemps
demain dans tout les films le 10 mai
c'est la journée nationale des mémoires
de la traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions à saint quentin en yvelines
comme chaque année une semaine de la
mémoire d' esclavage est organisée à
cette occasion la 10e édition se tient
du 4 au 10 mai avec nous en plateau pour
en parler
maryline lui
bonsoir bonsoir et merci de nous
recevoir merci à vous d'être venu vous
êtes la secrétaire du collectif qui
organise donc cet événement c'est le
collectif pour la semaine de la mémoire
de l'esclavagé à saint quentin en
yvelines alors quels sont les objectifs
de cet événement pourquoi avoir lancé
une telle semaine à saint quentin en
yvelines
alors cette ce collectif il existe la
10e édition de cette année et on a lancé
parce qu'il était important à la fois en
s'appuyant sur la loi taubira de donner
un peu plus de visibilité
parce qu'une date du 10 mai qui n'est
pas une un jour férié ne permettait pas
un véritablement d'apporter les éléments
d'information de sensibilisation à
l'ensemble des de la population tous
âges confondus
non c'est une histoire qui est lourde
pourquoi c'est important d'entretenir ce
dès ce devoir de mémoire
ça fait partie de l'histoire de la
france qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
tout pays à des tranches d'histoire un
peu plus sombre et cette tranche un peu
plus sombre sans jeu de mots il faut
l'aborder
il faut l'aborder mais l'aborder avec
des éléments tangibles des faits
historiques précis et non pas juste du
ressenti alors il faut l'aborder vous le
dites et l'idée aussi de cette semaine
c'est que ce soit quelque chose de
festif donc pour aussi parler à tous les
publics oui tout à fait c'est vrai que
comme vous le disiez s'éteint c'est
lourd et en particulier pour ceux dont
les ancêtres ont été esclaves et il peut
y avoir une envie de fuir de ne pas être
réduit à cela le but n'est pas de les
réduire à des descendants d'esclaves
bien au contraire mais de montrer qu'il
y avait une vraie civilisation avant et
qu'après il ya aussi une culture qui est
née aussi de cela et des personnes des
personnalités qui ont lutté que ce soit
pour les droits civiques aux états unis
mais aussi en france et permettre nous
permettre que
comment dirais-je que chacun prenne sa
place au sein de hausse 1 de la société
française
alors pour cette semaine chaque année il
ya un fil rouge cette année le fil rouge
c'est lutter engagement d'aujourd'hui
pour éradiquer les séquelles de la
traite et de l'esclavagé dans nos
sociétés voilà un fil rouge chaque année
quels sont justement les séquelles que
qui existe encore aujourd'hui et qui
sont dus à l esclavage quelles séquelles
on peut voir aujourd'hui il ya quand
même toujours la tentation de réduire
l'effet est un peu raciste des 'valeurs
dollar' de la vie quotidienne
singe vraiment ramener à des postures
qui sont désobligeantes et lissant
penser que voilà ce sont encore des
personnes qui n'ont pas d'histoire qui
n'ont pas de culture qui sont limite des
animaux ils n'ont quand même pas hésité
à le faire pour madame taubira qui est
quand même une figure de la de la
société de la politique donc voilà c'est
tout ça alors évidemment c'est vrai que
ça peut paraître prétentieux de dire
pour éradiquer et s'éteint c'est un
sujet de longue haleine en voit bien aux
états unis encore malgré tout et malgré
toutes les luttes conduite les les
travers persiste c'est qu'ils sont
lourds de conséquences parce qu'il ya
quand même des personnes tuées
en france on a on a quand même des
incidents qui arrivent vont beaucoup de
jeunes se plaignent d'être comment
dirais-je d'être victime du faciès
normal et c'est donc voilà et on a
besoin de leur donner une vraie et
d'enfin leur permettent de reconstruire
leur identité de manière ajustements se
construire par rapport à ça et non pas
par rapport à l'image qu'on leur envoie
chaque année c'est un programme riche
que propose cette semaine de la mémoire
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines pardon alors
ça commence pour cette édition vendredi
prochain le 4 mai par une projection et
ce qui sera suivie d'un débat ça se
passe au ciné 7 et donc voilà exactement
et donc je vous invite à venir
c'est vrai que chaque année on a à coeur
à trouver un film qui qui traitent du
sujet avec et du coup seul aspect visuel
qui peut être
qui peut chambouler oui voilà donc on me
n'est ce pas après partir comme ça parce
que le but c'est pas de générer de la
rancoeur des choses comme ça mais c'est
d'accompagner aussi tout ça mais ne pas
se voiler la face
donc véritablement ce film qui est parti
de des écrits de james baldwin
ce sont ces un début puisqu'il a eu le
temps de mourir avant d'avoir terminé
son livre et
le réalisateur haïtien raoul peck a est
partie de cela au pouvoir retracer
véritablement les luttes pour les droits
civiques et cette période où il y a
plusieurs qui ont laissé leur vie
deux autres programmations vouliez
mettre en avant une conférence qui se
déroule le 5 mai voilà ça c'est pas ça
trappe alors à la salle de conseil de
l'agglomération
donc c'est vrai que depuis plusieurs
années cette salle nous est prêtée et
c'est devenu un peu notre salle de
conférence d'accord et donc chaque là
encore chaque année nous nous efforçons
de faire venir des personnes de qualité
des historiens des chercheurs qui
peuvent nous apporter leur éclairage
avec vraiment des éléments tangibles
donc là encore je vous invite vivement
enfin en tout cas j'habite le public
vivement à venir très nombreux assister
à cette conférence pour pouvoir poser
des questions et pour pouvoir avoir des
éclairages et aller plus loin parce que
souvent nous proposons aussi des livres
qui permettent après d'aller plus loin
en 20 secondes je sais ça va être
difficile une dernière chose et ça
revient au côté festif dont on parlait
tout à l'heure il ya une journée
sportive qui organisait à montigny le
bretonneux gymnase alain colas et ça se
passe le 8 mai voilà alors c'est comment
dirais-je le gymnase pareil le gymnase
alain colas nous est toujours et donc
nous en remercions la mairie de montigny
qui chaque année nous prête ce gymnase
live qui nous permet de proposer un
certain nombre d'éléments ce pour
d'événements sportifs
comment dirais-je 2
du basket du stretching jamie bell etc
etc mais surtout il ya toujours une
exposition qui est proposée de manière à
ce que soient pas comment dire est que
ça ne reste pas juste un événement
sportif mais qu'elle se sera relié à
cette semaine et en profite pour
sensibiliser des publics plus jeunes aux
plus sportifs peut-être un peu plus
éloignés de ces problématiques là il
programme est en tout cas retrouver dans
son intégralité sur vous invite à aller
sur le site du collectif s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et n'hésitez pas à
télécharger le programme fait circuler
autour de vous et venez nombreux et où
comme on dirait ya aussi donc le leem et
donc la journée de clôture donc et là
aussi nous souhaitons nous vous
attendons nombreux
voilà donc le programme à retrouver sur
le site internet merci en tout cas à
marilyn lieu d'avoir été avec nous pour
parler de cette semaine de la mémoire de
l'esclavagé à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours où il
ya une nouvelle étape franchie pour les
travaux du pont schuller il relie à la
verrière à maurepas en passant au dessus
de la nationale 10
ce samedi les ouvriers ont coulé le
béton sur le nouveau tablier du pont les
détails avec ce sujet de nicolas
kirillovitch la dernière phase des
travaux du pont schuller est enclenché
la nouvelle partie du pont a été bétonné
par les ouvriers une épaisseur de 70 cm
coulé sur le tablier
il ya des équipes qui vibre le béton le
béton soit libre et pour faire sortir
les bulles d'air et
il ya d'autres équipes qui sont en train
de faire le tas le sage qu'on appelle
couramment des dalles agissent et
pour avoir pour avoir une surface
vraiment lice pour rappel cette partie
du pont sera destiné à la circulation
des bus dans les deux sens avec
l'objectif de fluidifier le trafic
routier sur cet itinéraire c'est la
dernière étape
on a vraiment du béton après derrière on
va passer qu'on appelle les finitions de
la mise en place de l'étanchéité la mise
en place des garde corps périphériques
et l'habillage en termes de serrurerie
dont et pornichet l'extérieur et donc
tout ça ça nous amène si vous voulez en
gros le pont ils seraient extraits
circulent à bron septembre 2018 les
ouvriers entameront à ce moment là une
phase de rénovation du pont existant
la circulation se fera sur la nouvelle
partie de l'infrastructure l'ensemble
des travaux devraient se terminer à la
fin de l'année 2018 et j'accueille à
présent sur ce plateau gilles moutier
bonsoir bonsoir la cimade vite et vous
êtes l'ipo diacre de la paroisse
orthodoxe saint jean cassien
sainte-geneviève une paroisse de saint
quentin en yvelines elle a été fondée au
début des années 2000 l'installation à
saint quentin en yvelines s'est déroulée
en 2012 alors nicolas landry a assisté
hier dimanche à une messe de votre
communauté la voix de ce reportage est
signée mélanie poker
le corps et le sang du christ ne font
qu'un une communion donnée à la cuillère
la religion orthodoxe ces deux mille ans
de liturgie proche de la religion
catholique s'est toujours l'évangile
chez lui avec une des pistes avant le
credo le notre père et communion et le
renvoi après j'ai eu des petits
changements quand même au juge mentionne
tout de suite plus courte que ça mais
surtout par piété par souci de mieux
prier les officiers géorgiens ont pu
suivre les fusions est longue des messes
en français et en roumain la création de
cette paroisse serait pour aux demandes
des pratiques aux présentes depuis six
ans sur saint quentin en yvelines ces
messes dominicales rassemble une
cinquantaine de fidèles réguliers on est
bien ensemble déjà pour commencer on se
soutient et on soutient aussi les hôtes
et aussi ont respecté les autres c'est
le respect si vous voulez j'étais
catholique
donc j'ai j'ai été baptisé catholique
j'ai fait mon catéchisme
et caetera donc j'ai été communier donc
je suis venu à l'orthodoxie
pour pouvoir me marier avec ma femme qui
est russe dans la forme ça beaucoup il
ya beaucoup de différences et notamment
une fête une sorte de rigueur qui est
qui en fait un petit peu perdues en fait
dans le catholicisme
donc beaucoup de règles en fait à suivre
une messe terminée ce dimanche par la
chorale dessin parc anger une chorale
romaine parisienne une vingtaine de
chanteurs pour partager des airs
populaires et pour parler de la présence
orthodoxe à saint quentin en yvelines
jean moutier est avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes l'ipo diacre de la
paroisse saint jean avec a61 sainte
geneviève qui est donc présentes sur le
territoire
vous êtes également et c'est votre
activité professionnelle physicien
nucléaire
la religion et les sciences peuvent pas
tout à fait à l'ensemble des écoutes et
j'en suis l'illustration et je pense que
je ne suis pas la seule illustration je
connais un certain nombre de monde de
personnes qui ont effectivement des
professions dans le domaine de la
recherche des sciences dites dures et ça
n'est absolument pas incompatibles bien
au contraire lorsqu'on lit les évangiles
de nombreuses fois le christ explique
qu'il faut utiliser sa raison aussi pour
faire la différence entre ce qui est
faux et entre ce qui est vrai et que la
raison permet de trier le bon grain de
l'ivraie
donc je jour précise juste parce que je
n'ai pas dit en début d'entretien que
cette paroisse et bien sûr située à 50
en une sur la commune de trappe alors ça
permet aussi de souligner à travers au
travers de votre profession la cie
différence avec le catholicisme le
clergé orthodoxe n'est pas salarié de
l'église
là une profession à côté le clara une
profession à côté alors c'est vrai en
france c'est moins vrai dans les pays
d'europe de l'est où l'orthodoxie est
présente depuis depuis depuis 2000 ans
et qui restait présente pendant 2000 ans
s'est par contre vrai en france parce
que l'orthodoxie est une petite
communauté qui n'a pas forcément les
moyens de subvenir à son clergé donc le
clergé les prêtres et diacres
effectivement travail là pour la plupart
d'entre eux en journée sauf est en
retraite ce qui les empêche d'être
présents 24 heures sur 24 dans leur
communauté
oui autre différence par rapport aux
catholiques le clergé et marié et dans
certains pays c'est même obligatoire
l'orthodoxie orthodoxie la doc si c'est
là c'est là c'est là là c'est la voix
c'est la vérité ortho ses droits donc
c'est la ligne droite la voie droite qui
n'a pas varié depuis
depuis le christ et les apôtres et donc
la tradition a continué et depuis
l'origine le clergé de type rabbinique
au départ était marié et donc le clergé
continue à être mariés
effectivement c'est aussi une des
raisons est aussi de dire comment avoir
une activité pastorale c'est à dire
comprendre les paroissiens et les
conseillers si on ne vit pas en même
temps la vie que eux-mêmes mène donc oui
effectivement le clergé et marié une
fois qu'il est ordonné il ne peut plus
ni se marier s'ils n'étaient pas mariés
et finalement pas divorcer aussi il est
marié qui le souhaitaient d'accord alors
parlons de l'organisation maintenant de
l'orthodoxie en france votre paroisse
dépend du patriarcat roumain il ya
plusieurs patriarcat en france russe
grecque roumaine bien d'autres encore
expliquez-nous un peu ce fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'ya pas une seule
église orthodoxe de france
non c'est particulier à l'europe de
l'est comme je les dis l'orthodoxie
alors de l'ouest car dans l'orthodoxie
il faut il faut quand même imaginer que
pendant mille ans les premiers milan il
n'y avait pas de catholicisme romain ni
de catholicisme orthodoxes il n'y avait
qu'une seule église indivisible et en
1054 la séparation commence à se faire
et là l'europe de l'ouest bifurque vers
le catholicisme romain pendant que les
europe de l est
elle continue sur la voie du
catholicisme qui ne s'appelait pas
orthodoxe qui avait pas de différence
d'accord et donc la tradition culturelle
de l'europe de l'ouest c'est le
catholicisme est pas l'orthodoxie et
donc le l'orthodoxie s'est constitué en
europe de l'ouest et donc en france
grâce aux diasporas donc la première
diaspora ce sont les russes lors de la
révolution de 1917 puis ensuite divers
diaspora des divers pays de l'est
roumanie bulgarie grèce et c'est très
bien avec les invasions et ça explique
que chacune de ses diasporas puisqu'il
n'y avait pas d'églises orthodoxes en
france chacune de ses diasporas a
constitué sa propre église est donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve à
effectivement ne pas avoir une église
orthodoxe de france
mais à voir l'église orthodoxe en france
avec une représentation de chacun des
patriarcats des pays d'europe de l'est
en france ce qui veut dire que
l'orthodoxie en france est administré
par une assemblée ce qu'on appelle
l'assemblée des évêques orthodoxes de
france qui se réunissent régulièrement
pour décider de certaines choses de
façon commune ensemble un petit mot pour
terminer nous reste un peu plus d'une
minute sur la présence donc orthodoxe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines votre paroisse
on l'a dit est présente sur le
territoire depuis 2012 et vous êtes la
seule paroisse orthodoxe sur le
territoire de 50 ans absolument nous
sommes un seul paroisse orthodoxe
on y rajoutant le petit monastère du
saint-esprit qui est à ménil aux mains
du syndic et qui est à ce qu'on appelle
un ce kit avec est dirigée par le père
manager bernard oui nous sommes la seule
communauté avec ce monastère sur 51 et
cinquantaine de fidèles
c'est ça une cinquantaine de fidèles en
moyenne plus lorsqu'il ya des grands
événements mais c'est effectivement ce
que sairgroup et une paroisse qui est
par construction éminemment
multiculturelle on l'a dit nous sommes
rattachés au patriarcat de roumanie en
france mais la paroisse contient des
serbes des bulgares et des roumains des
français qui sont mariés à des conjoints
de nationalité bulgare serbe mènera mais
des français aussi de france sarah qu'on
a vu dans le reportage était troupes
éthiopiennes et ce qui nous réunit c'est
la pratique de l'orthodoxie dans la
langue commune qui est le français
est-ce que depuis 2012 il ya des
nouveaux fidèles qu'ils ont sont arrivés
seul absolument oui nous grossissons et
ben merci d'avoir été avec nous gym si
il peux diacre de la paroisse saint jean
cassien sainte geneviève qui est
présente donc à saint quentin en
yvelines on le rappelle depuis 2012 et
vous pouvez retrouver plus
d'informations sur la paroisse sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
le sport un mot de football alors que la
finale de la compétition se jouera le 8
mai entre le paris saint-germain et les
herbiers le premier tour de la prochaine
coupe de france s'est joué à ce week-end
villepreux club de troisième division de
district s'est imposé chez les
essonniens de draveil un club qui évolue
une division au-dessus des yvelinois est
le résumé du match avec michael et demi
d'euros et nicolas d'andrus une victoire
au bout du suspense villepreux a réussi
à se qualifier pour le deuxième tour de
la coupe de france grâce à ce coup franc
zidanesque pourtant rien n'a été simple
pour les villes prodi en face à draveil
mené 1 à 0 et réduits à dix en début de
match les rouges auraient agi promeut
les deux buses avant la mi temps
malheureusement non prend un rouge un
peu
configs a accepté malgré qui fixait les
règles ils font cinq six sept huit
fautes ils n'ont pas un carton à dix
contre onze on est en train de faire du
daim on continue le travail qu'on
entraîne pour faire depuis des matchs et
des matches le travail va finir par
payer à la fin au retour des vestiaires
les villes président souffre face au
pensionnaire de deuxième division de
district draveil fini par égaliser à
deux buts partout sur corner enfin quand
on est revenu on s'est dit qu'on défende
et solidaire et on a défendu peut-être
un peu trop bas un but encaissé qui a
servi d'électrochoc villepreux poussé
fini par marquer le but de la victoire
dans les dernières secondes
score final 3 buts avant sa délivrance
c'est le résultat de deux mois deux mois
de travail une délivrance allait jouer
une équipe eu une division au dessus on
va en fusion comme il a dit 80 minutes à
dix c'est compliqué c'est là la
récompense comme je l'aurais dit dans le
petit message ça reste la coupe de
france c'est la télé qui vient il ya les
supporters sont là et ainsi de suite
faites vous plaisir avant tout ce sera
un résultat prochain tour proville pro
début juin contre un adversaire encore
inconnu les supporters eux commence à
prendre goût à la coupe de ils étaient
partis à vélo depuis le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
22 avril dernier 7 jours et 6 117 km
plus tard et gabin 10 ans est arrivé à
brest samedi dernier accompagné de son
papa et de son grand père le jeune
cycliste a bouclé son paris brest pour
la bonne cause
une aventure au profit de l'association
vaincre la mucoviscidose
une amie de sa femme il est touché par
la maladie et gabon a ainsi pu récolter
presque 4000 euros et a été accueilli
samedi avec les honneurs
il revient sur son périple interrogé par
nicolas landry pas ce s'est bien passé
se peut la rendre dernière étape il y
avait beaucoup de vent et beaucoup de
pluie bat comme un voulait pas peter et
et ça nous fatigue et patrons vont aller
à la fac de médecine au laboratoire de
recherche et on allait faire note
pourrait arriver aux capucins soucier
bresse le lie à vue et mini paris brest
et y avait plein de monde et gabin va se
remettre en selle très vite ils se
reposent en vue de sa prochaine course
cycliste le 13 mai
2 les saluts d'arrêter encore et du
loisir avant de refermer ce journal la
15e édition de la prairial de montigny
le bretonneux se déroulait ce week-end
près de 4000 visiteurs sont venus
acheter des fleurs des produits
régionaux ou encore rencontrer et des
poules et des lapins un événement
organisé par le lions club de la ville
pour financer un chien guide d'aveuglé
nicolas landry c'est la poule noire
entièrement noir qui vient d'indonésie
cette poule c la sema ni une race élevé
par camille jalu cette étudiante en 6e
année de médecine participe à sa
première prairial à montigny le
bretonneux avec quelques volailles et
des lapins ça touche est à la fois mais
les deux activités la principale vu que
je suis en médecine donc la cécité sorte
et puis ça a touché aussi ma petite
passion aux loisirs à côté les poules
les volailles donc c'était fait pour moi
c'était parfait et je suis ravi alors
avec ma fille on regarde l épaule et ses
magnifiques poule et c'est super beau
lapin j'aime bien les animaux quand j'en
vois j'ai envie de caresser vous adoptez
des animaux mais aussi des fleurs et des
produits gastronomiques
au total près de 50 exposants ont
participé à cette 15e édition à la ferme
du man est un événement organisé par le
lion's club de montigny le bretonneux
pour aider au financement de chiens
guides d'aveuglés ça ne se vend pas mais
ça a un coût parce que il faut l'élever
il est élevé au centre de buc juste à
côté
ensuite il faut le nourrir il faut
l'éduquer
il faut tout curan de sa vie le soigner
lui donner à manger et ensuite il faut
lui préparer sa retraite
le lion's club unis montrent un a déjà
financé cinq chiens guides
avec environ dix mille euros collectés
lors de la pré real 2018
l'organisation va participer au
financement d'un sixième compagnon c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi replay reportage à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]